[Music]
oh yes High Praise for President Joe
Biden from illegal migrants crossing the
southern border uh illegally as Customs
and Border Protection agents have been
overwhelmed with the surge of illegal
border crossings last week a record
12,000 people came into America in one
day uh Customs and Border Patrol sources
telling Fox News that already over
535,000 migrants have been apprehended
at the border for this fiscal year which
started in October in addition there
have been more than 60,000 gotway that
disappeared into the United States with
Untold more entering undetected Fox News
is now learning that CBP officials
privately told Arizona lawmakers that on
average 5,000 migrants are released into
the country every day joining me right
now on how Biden's border crisis is
impacting US National Security and the
fight underway to stop it instead of
sending more money to Ukraine is Kansas
Senator Roger Marshall Senator it's good
to see you thanks very much for being
here today good morning I want to get
your take on this because of course you
were on the Senate Homeland security
committee as well as the Senate budget
committee how would you assess the
Border today we got this new news this
morning that 5,000 people are being
released into the country every day
right the Border situation is getting
worse every day record days 10,000
11,000 12,000 people crossing our border
every day remember since Joe Biden
became president 10 million people have
crossed the border illegally and this is
why FBI director Ray is saying we've
never had a a a more unsecure situation
right now all the lights are blinking
red
all at the same time the first time in
his career so this is getting steadily
worse where are these 10 million people
at least 1.7 million got aways where are
those people what are they doing uh I I
think everybody should be watching their
back uh we're looking at live pictures I
want to point out of lukeville Arizona
these are this is happening right now
these are live pictures here in uh the
at the Border in Arizona and of course
we know that customs in Border Patrol
had to move Agents from lukeville uh to
other areas of the Border because all
the uh border openings were uh basically
seeing a massive surge can you tell us a
little about what's going on in Texas
and Arizona right now right so remember
this the border patrol officers can only
process about a thousand people a day so
they're being overwhelmed here when 10
11 12,000 people are coming across the
border basically these border patrol
agents turn into uh babysitters and
social workers and nurses and again
Maria you've been to the Border as well
but my last trip there the border patrol
officer said if you could give us one
thing make policy changes so that's why
we're fighting with Joe Biden saying no
money for Ukraine until we fix the
Border it's the border the border the
Border we have to secure the border and
with some simple policy changes like
Asylum and parole changes we can impact
75% of the people that are coming to our
Southern border right now so policy
change alone would fix the problem Joe
Biden could have done that yesterday the
week before he won't do it so we need to
do it legally through the through
Congress well I I don't understand why I
mean I'm going to get back to the fight
in a moment because that's another head
scratcher the fact that this President
will not make any changes at the border
until you agree to give more money to
Ukraine we've already sent Ukraine about
$ 1110 billion dollar I believe but what
what is this new uh element from Senator
Dick Durban the other day your colleague
dick Durban proposed to allow illegal
migrants to serve in the US military are
you serious yeah I think that's
nonstarter for us so we kicked military
people out of the service because they
refused the covid vaccine but we're
going to let people that have broke the
law into the military um look if you
have a legal status then I think there
could be consideration but look if
you're an illegal person in the United
States you can't go in the military
right now uh again these people have not
been vetted um my goodness there's been
70,000 60 70,000 people aliens from
foreign countries of Interest as well
hundreds of terrorists have AC crossed
our border as well that's not a good
solution well you questioned Christopher
Ray I saw the hearing you were great
with Christopher Ray but everything he
said was quite scary he said we are now
at uh a peak in terms of the potential
for a terrorist attack on the United
States on us soil he tried to blame the
Hamas attack on on Israel instead of the
wide openen border then you've got these
Chinese migrants coming in flooding in
and when we've got pictures of these
Chinese Nationals coming in they're
largely M military AED men I mean can
you just pick up and leave China and say
I'm going to go to America now don't you
need approval is is Xi Jinping directing
these people to come into America and
settle here we have to assume so look
it's a sad day when the Chinese
Communist Party pays more attention to
our Southern border than the White House
does to your point 24,000 Chinese
nationalists have crossed the border
under Joe Biden those people have now
taken positions throughout the country
uh they're running their police stations
here in New York City um people then
they're keeping track of their own folks
making sure they're staying in order
they're the money collectors on the end
of the fenel as well they're setting up
confucious schools um they've
infiltrated our research and they're
buying Farmland next to military bases
all things you've reported on Maria uh I
would I would just say it's worse than
what you're saying it's even worse than
what the media is describing Chinese in
influence in this country not to mention
you know not to mention they're stealing
$500 billion do of intellectual property
from US every year 90% of the
counterfeits that come into this country
they gave us a virus that killed a
million people the fitel is killing 300
people every day hundreds of thousands
of people have died because of Chinese
fitel under Joe Biden's watch how how
does Joe Biden sleep at night how does
his DHS secretary sleep at night I I
just don't understand this and and of
course none of these issues ever come up
when he meets with Jan ping again none
of this came out uh with his last
meeting in ji Jinping and my question is
why why won't he hold the Chinese
Communist Party accountable why does he
have this wide open border there is a
report about uh New York Republican um
Nicole malot tacus in Staten Island and
she says that she got a portion of the
she submitted a request for the Freedom
of Information law and she got a portion
of uh the contract between a nonprofit
organization tasked with erecting
Emergency Shelters for migrants and she
say she found in that contract that it
obligates contractors of Migrant
shelters to hand out voter registration
cards to hand out uh to help migrants in
registering to vote and circulate
campaign materials within the shelter
premises is that what you know do you
have any information about that is that
is that the point here to get these
migrants to vote Democrat you absolutely
that that's the only thing you could
assume if Joe Biden wanted to secure the
Border he could secure it but instead
that they think this is the future of
the Democrat Party they're doing this in
all government institutions whether it's
a place you go uh to get your food
stamps or whether it's a place you go to
get free health care they're
infiltrating all those they meeting the
Biden Administration with taxpayer
dollars are out there trying to get
people registered and as well so it is
absolutely the only thing that makes
sense again they're willing to sacrifice
300 Young Americans every day to build
their own Democrat party but I think the
good news is Americans are are they know
what's going on and that's why the
Americans are leaving the Democrat Party
in groves and they're looking for a new
leadership there's a lot of why
questions today Maria but I think
ultimately the ultimate Choice here will
become November of 2024 will Americans
choose a new president on this fight in
terms of money to Ukraine where is this
going all are leaving for the holidays
next Thursday uh are you going to agree
to send money to Ukraine or are you
going to hold the line until you see
policy changes at the border yeah I've
never seen the Republicans so together
standing up all 49 of us voting against
this big hundred billion doll
supplemental package uh from the
president Chuck Schumer unless we get
meaningful border security and I don't
see that happening I think that Chuck
Schumer Joe Biden bow to their
immigration uh people that's the
immigration Lobby it's the same group of
people that are pro Palestine and they
don't want to take this vote we've given
the Democrats four opportunities to vote
for Standalone Israel funding they voted
it down every time we could attack every
one of these uh four prongs of this
riddle the supplemental riddle one at a
time and I think figure out Solutions
but none of it happens until we secure
the Border it's the border the Border
it's the Border yeah now all right real
quick before you go Senator I know you
were at the young Republicans event last
night in New York City where former
president Trump spoke we have a sound
bite of that I want to get your reaction
ction to what the crowd did after he
said this watch okay these are not
indictments in the traditional sense
these are Biden indictments against
their this is just against a political
opponent and with that he's opened up a
Pandora's Box that may never let our
country be the same they've opened up a
Pandora box and I only can say to Joe is
be very careful what you wish for cuz
what you've done is a terrible thing
wow Senator uh will Donald Trump be the
nominee he is he is the presumptive
nominee I think he's ahead by 50 or 60
points and I remember what Bob Dole
always told me when there was tough
decisions he said go back and listen to
the people of Kansas the Republicans of
Kansas want want Donald Trump to be
their nominee and to be their next
president as well I would just caution
people though as they listening to all
this this R Ric this is an hour and a
half long speech last night and by the
way what came through to me was Donald
Trump loves New York City that this is
his home he's so proud of New York City
and he's so upset that it's gone to HL
right so he's so upset about this but
I'm reminded what n griid told me uh
just like months after Donald Trump was
elected in 2016 he said look Donald
Trump's going to be a third Andrew
Jackson a third Teddy Roosevelt and a
third barn and Bailey so president Trump
spends a lot of time just shining a
flashlight and letting that left
National media chase the flashlight a
lot a lot so I wouldn't overreact to
every word he says but he's going to be
the president of National Security he's
going to secure the Border he's going to
make the economy strong his enemies will
fear us and respect us all right Senator
thanks very much Kansas Senator Roger
Marshall we so appreciate your time this
morning thank you sir thank you Maria
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else